I'm Matt Prior producer for EA Sports
2014 fifa world cup brazil and this is
your inside look at how we brought the
world cup to life within our game we've
built 21 brand new venues including all
12 of the authentic Brazilian world cup
stadium so you can play in fully
rendered arenas such as Sao Paulo das
dunas the arrow Rio the American are and
more we've also included 19 officially
licensed managers from roy hodgson to
vincent del Bosque so you can experience
their presence on the pitch as you take
on the world's greatest team use 2014
world cup brazil is EA sports talk radio
with this you'll receive dynamic
tournament updates as you play through
different modes from your choice of Andy
Goldstein in Ian Darke other men in
blazers michael Davies and Roger Bannon
thousands of players have dreamt of
representing their nations just 23 will
have the honor through them a
goalkeepers when you play 2014 world cup
brazil you're going to feel the support
of an entire nation with all new crowd
scenes including banners flags and see
cards in the stadium as well as from
live city events in all corners of the
world when you score a goal with England
you'll see the fans cheering live in
Trafalgar Square win with France can
you'll see crowds going wild at the Arc
de Triomphe our all new crowd renderings
bring the World Cup atmosphere to life
and add flavor to the world's greatest
tournament the FIFA World Cup